-So I want to ask this.
Recently, Sean Spicer,
the President's
first press secretary,
returned to
the press briefing room
to ask a question for
the news organization Newsmax.
Was that strange
for you and your colleague
to see someone who had bee
behind the podium
you know, sort of sitting
in the pen with you guys?
-It was definitely surreal
because he, I think,
is the first White House
press secretary to then question
as a member of the media the
same President that he served.
So it was very surprising.
I will tell you a quick story.
Because I literally
clean everything like crazy,
I was sitting
next to Sean Spicer,
but I was cleaning my chai
so hard and so long
that I literally did not realize
that Sean Spicer was sitting
next to me,
until he was like, "Hi,"
and I was like,
"Oh, my gosh!
It's Sean Spicer."
So I think that tells you
what moment we're living in,
that we're so crazy,
I'm wiping down things
with hand sanitizer
and have to sit next to
and am sitting next to
the former
White House press secretary,
who's now a member of the media.
-We have a newly former
White House press secretar
joining the ranks --
that's Stephanie Grisham -
who, in her time having the job,
did not hold
a single press conference.
What do you think that say
in regards to the strategy
this administration
seems to have
with their relationship
to the press?
-Well, Stephanie Grisham
never held
a White House press briefing
because President Trump,
frankly, didn't want her t
and didn't see a need
for press briefings.
And even when he now
sees a need for press briefings,
largely because this is th
number-one way that he's abl
to speak to the media
and speak to the American people
that he now thinks
it's an important thing.
But I think what it tells us
is that the President
understands media.
He understands prime time.
He understands how to choose
what he's saying.
So I think that it tells you
that the White House briefin
just wasn't important
until he could no longer
hold rallies
and can no longer hold other
kind of alternate medias,
and this is the number-one way
that he's able to get coverage
-There was a lot of talk
even before the last election,
"How do you cover a Trump rally?
Is it the right thing
to put it on television,
unedited, live,
as it's happening?"
The same question now
is being asked
about these press conferences.
You know,
there are some media critics
who don't think they should be
on TV every night.
As somebody who's in that room
you know, how --
what do you think
is the right way to presen
those press briefings
as they're happening?
-So, it's really not my jo
to figure out whether or not
we cover them live.
What I can say is that,
when I'm covering them,
I try to add as much context
and fact-checking as possible,
because I think,
covering President Trump,
I've learned
you have to have context.
You have to tell people,
"Here's what the facts are
and here's when he's wrong
and here's when he's right."
-I think for people like mysel
who watch at home,
one thing we enjoy to see --
enjoy seeing, excuse me --
is that sometimes the Presiden
will cut off a reporter
without asking --
answering a question.
And the next reporter will the
follow-up on behalf
of their colleague
who had the previous question.
Do you wish that happened more
and do you think it's importan
for the press to be unifie
in those moments
where one will get cut off
-I think it's important
to follow-up
on each other's questions,
for sure.
Especially, because some o
the questions that we're askin
are the basic questions.
The question is still,
"If you need a test,
can you get a test?
Will we have enough ventilators?
What is the President doin
to make sure that people
are gonna stay safe?
When is the White House
gonna say, 'You know what?
Maybe the government
can open back up
and we can all go back
to our normal lives?'
How many people
do we think are gonna die?
Those are basic questions
that, at times,
we're not getting answers to
So I think those questions can
and should continue to be asked.
-This is, obviously,
a case where the President
has been aggressive
with all walks of life
if they're journalists.
Yet it has been pointed ou
that he has been
particularly aggressive
with female journalists
and with journalists of color.
Obviously,
you tick both those boxes.
Do you feel
that there's truth to that
And what do you think that
again, says about this momen
we're living through?
-I think the President
wants to have an opponent,
and he wants
to have a foil at all times.
And whether or not that's
going after me
or going after
Jonathan Karl of ABC
or Peter Alexander of NBC,
he just, at times,
I think, wants a fight,
wants a punching bag.
And as we get into the fall,
he's gonna then turn
to Joe Biden.
He's gonna turn to the media
that's been, of course,
a long foil of his.
So I think in some ways,
I'm not sure
if he's particularly
picking on black women
as much as he's
particularly picking on anyone
that he sees as a threat.
-Well, I really genuinely
want to thank you
for bringing the integrity
that you bring
to those White House
press briefings.
We're really lucky
to have journalists like you
in the room.
And thank you so much
for making time for us tonight
-Thanks so much for having me.